everyone Steve Elantra with Collider and
I am here with the people behind the boy
who harnessed the wind are you guys
doing good
as I was saying off-camera just a little
bit ago it was like 10 years ago that we
first I think it was my first interview
with you and it was like oh seven oh
eight we were at the myspace cafe
MySpace which is nearby and we were
outdoors talking about red red belts and
some other stuff and I and you can tell
the difference between both of us
because back then you walked up by
yourself
to do the interview I walked up by
myself to do the interview put the
camera on a tripod and we just sat there
talking I sometimes still walk places
but that's rare usually there's an
entourage with you I've seen a paparazzi
photos but what I'm saying is now
there's like a team of people and you
know we have actual cameras and so I
appreciate you taking charity on me back
then uh-huh and giving me some time now
where now I'm knocking down the door
right exactly so I want to jump right on
in first which is a lot of people who
will be watching this won't have have
seen the movie yet and hate asking the
generic thing but can you both talk a
little bit about talk a little about
what it's about sure so the boy who
harnessed the wind is a story of William
kam Wamba who when he was 13 years old
was in a situation with his family in
and his community in Malawi when there
was a famine a family hit this this area
of Malawi education in Malawi isn't
isn't free in secondary school he so he
was taken out of school and and the
family sort of and the community kind of
knuckle down and brace for the worst
essentially and this terrible kind of
tragedy which which struck them and in
that and the timeless was happening
William managed to sneak into the school
sneaking back into school he found an
American textbook called using energy
and on the front of it is a picture of a
windmill and so he started to build
together using junk and scratch a scrap
metal that he could find in the local
area and started to put together a wind
turbine in order to ultimately
generate electricity power water pumps
irrigate the land and end famine in the
region your story's incredible and it
I'm just curious what has it been like
for you watching this whole thing unfold
from because you've done interviews
you've been yeah people know you around
the world I'm just curious what this
whole process has been like for you it
has been really amazing a process to me
when I was studying like building my
winomi I didn't imagine like he one day
I'll be sitting here studying like
question like interview I was just like
doing it like to solve the problem that
we are facing at that time but to me
having a chance to be interviewed I
think that it's gonna a lot of people
gonna be able like to Lane about my
story they might learn something about
me that might help their own lives they
might have who they might be facing some
challenges maybe the same challenges
that I face or it might be completely
different challenges but they might be
able like to learn from me and being
able like to to do what they can do in
order like to help out with their
communities and also like their families
I'm curious with every movie that's
based on something that really happened
you're trying to tell the most honest
version of that story that you can but
you're also making a movie so I'm just
curious balancing that line of fact
versus fiction with what I'm talking
about and so let me just start with that
yeah just I mean with any film exactly
as you say you know you're trying to
sort of balance those two things they're
trying to create a very for me I wanted
to create a very authentic experience
this is why we shot in Malawi we shot in
in Winn Bay we shot right next door to
Williams house actually and and in with
the community and some of the people
that were that are in the film
experience some of the things that had
happened you know especially the
background and and the extras and stuff
so I wanted to really try and create
that authentic experience at the same
time you know this is a very epic story
it's an epic life you know and and there
are very epic lives that go on there
even though they're kind of these
slightly remote areas of the world and
I'd wanted to reflect that in the kind
of epic scale of of the film and the
scope of the film
so kind of that so this question is sort
of balancing van and then you know when
writing the screenplay and the depth in
the screenplay and condensing everything
and streamlining things and trying to
tell this story in a kind of condensed
fashion and using all of that to tell
the story in them in the most effective
way but maintaining I hope a real strong
sense of its truth sure I have to I'm
curious what was it like watching the
film for the first time and what was it
like for you because I'm sure it did I'm
sure you were nervous the first time
he's watching it so I'm just curious
what was your reaction as you're
watching it and what would you like
I had liked it was like exciting and
also like challenging at the same time I
had like mixed feeling because he they
were like some-some scene in the movie
it takes me back in the time when you
were like they difficult time that we
are going through so to relieve that to
relieve that he asked question to me it
was very hard like remembering or the
famine thing like happening not be for
me not being able like to go to school
remembering those like he to me it was
just like it was hard but they were like
some moments that I was like wow I
remember this like exactly how I used
like to do this this way and he it
brought like something like good
memories to me so I think I had like
this type of like mixed feeling because
of they the circumstances that happened
when he our see when I was building
there with me or like during the time
that they hang goes going on within like
they the country yeah I'm curious well
we like a little bit of nail-biting
while he's watching it or a hundred
percent you know I was very hours I mean
I was excited for him to see the foam
but obviously you know just as William
describes you know that these were very
traumatic events for him you know so it
was just a question of wanting to be
truthful and not shy away from how
difficult a situation he was in
but also I was just aware that it was
it's a complicated thing for him to
watch and to relive and to go back into
at that space in that time but he did an
amazing thing and and I
you know overall I just wanted to
celebrate that and to celebrate him and
celebrate his achievements it inspired
me I think it could inspire so many
people globally so what how long did you
know that you wanted to write and direct
and do stand and become a director and
what is it like also starring in the
movie that you've written and you're
directing because it's you know acting
is a challenge on its own yeah and then
you add the everything else it was
really his story that made me want to do
what to tell the story you know like I
just said that then the process started
with kind of adapting start you know
about ten years ago maybe not long after
we met it's possible the you know and
then sort of starting with adapting and
then you know really meeting William
going back and forth to Malawi over
several years and then and then
realizing that I was very much inside
the story and I wanted to direct the
film and on all of those things and then
the process of actually doing that is
it's really only possible if you're
going to try and put on all those hats
if you have just a strong team of
collaborators that you're working with
and I was very lucky to have you know
Thule peak who's an extraordinary
production designer designed City of God
and bear Salgado who's the costume
designer in city of got so they all came
out from Brazil dick Pope's
cinematographers incredible you know a
legendary cinematographer and and a
brilliant Valerio Benelli who's our
editor and they were all you know
obviously dick Pope but also Valerio you
know we all came down and camped out in
the hotel together and so we were just
working through and talking and you know
going you know going through everything
every day you know very sort of
intensely and and that kind of dynamic
and those kind of collaborators allowed
me the freedom to to also you know be in
the film and feel like I could engage in
being an actor as well I'm always
curious about the editing process talk a
little bit about what you learned in the
editing room and maybe changes that you
made based on a release Crean --ax well
I mean so many you know I think every
time you screen the film and you know we
were editing as we wished as we were
shooting so
so we would have ideas about how things
were wood wood layout and how things
would work and then we'd go out and
shoot the next day bring that stuff you
know in and then it would affect the
nature of everything and just keeping
very alive to what people were doing
what actors were doing and and how
they're you know an act as investment
changes some of the narrative and what
people are bringing to something and
then yeah when you're when you're later
on going out screening the film you know
testing the film and and then bringing
back that information and looking at
some of the things you know that things
people say and people feel about it and
all of that is just it's a great
extraordinary learning curve an amazing
process I definitely want to have to
talk about Netflix and the fact what was
the relationship like making the film
just talk about working for them so
looking with them yeah and what Netflix
came on board after the film was made
and and it's been exceptional you know
and it's such a it's you know when I was
first looking at the film and trying to
make the film and trying to think and
visit how I would get this film out it
is the kind of global community just
globally just get it released globally
because I feel like it's such a global
story and such an important story it was
hard to imagine how that was going to be
possible in this sort of sort of the
traditional model you know so there was
always a concern that it would be a
small like a small film that wouldn't
really find and I was very determined to
you know keep it to Chua
language you know very prominent in the
film you know there's a lot of English
but there's a lot of to adjust to keep
this sort of authenticity of the firm
and the sort of its internal integrity
and you know but all those things have
been sort of more challenging in the
past and then and you know and what's
amazing about Netflix is that that
there's there's this opportunity to have
a limited theatrical release for the
film so people can see it in the cinema
but then also you know to go on platform
is to really do that thing and get it
and get it right out there and people
have at least the opportunity really to
to really engage with Williams story
so I couldn't be happier you know that
that this is arrived now as I've made
this film you know to to really have a
real way of a delivery system for it's
crazy I believe it comes out on March
1st yeah it's it has is it a little
weird to realize that on March 1st I
believe there is a hundred and sixty
countries that Netflix has that I mean
like the whole world on one day are
gonna be able to watch this story it's
crazy yeah it's it's like it's amazing
because for me when he I was writing a
book with my co-author Brian and one
thing that I really wanted to do it's
like I did wanted like to share my story
off the list of the world and the in
much face to when they move it's gonna
be able like being like least some
people didn't have a chance to read my
book they're gonna be able to learn
about my story through the movie so I'm
very excited to see how how many people
I'm gonna be able like to they're gonna
be able like to know and truly and about
like my story completely if I'm not
mistaken you just there's a press
release it just went out recently where
you signed on to direct something else
sure what what's the project what's it
about and is it something that you're
far along in development so yeah the
project is the the short and tragic life
of Robert piece and it's an
extraordinary book written by Jeff Hobbs
who was Robert pieces roommates at Yale
Rob pace grew up in New Jersey and you
know in sort of what would be called
it's kind of sub optimal circumstances
went to Yale was an incredibly bright
student and his life you know and that
took a very tragic turn so it's a story
that I have been very excited about and
I'm and we're in the process now of kind
of fully developing the film and so I'm
excited to bring that it's now that you
brought it up I'm remembering the story
and it's about if I'm not mistaken it's
about someone who had a lot of promise
and ended up not fulfilling his hope the
optimistic destiny that almost you know
what I mean totally yeah I'm not
mistaken
yeah so do you have a script are you
writing it I am I am adapting the book
yeah and so are you and if you started
writing I have yeah
and so where are you in the writing
process I am in the writing I am taking
a break from the writer price to to
promote your other exactly uh well I'm
just gonna ask you about the writing
process cuz is is do you find that a lot
of writers I speak to you they talk
about and also for you they talk about
with the writing process having like a
magic hour where they wake up and they
feel very creative and they can write
for a few hours and then they feel like
tapped out and they have to do other
things and others can write from like
9:00 to 5:00 every day it's just their
job what was it like for you writing the
book and did you have a certain type of
thing and what's it like for you as a
screenwriter I think I think for me it
was more for like just like remembering
the events that took place and the
putting that like down into into a paper
everything that I could remember just
like putting like down and then sharing
that with my mic off and my Kaufer be
able like to relight that in to like
English and any sharing back with me say
like is this what he you read is this
what you meant so some areas are be like
oh okay
here like you miscoded me I meant like
this I mean thesis so that process it
was where like doing it like over and
over so it didn't have like he I didn't
have like a specific time say like this
the morning that I'm gonna be like
lighting but sure any time I'll just
like remember or like on this day like
this what happened yeah I'm sort of a
bit of both actually both of the ways
that you describe like I kind of end up
sometimes being able to just work
through the day but most of the time
it's like a specific period of time that
seems good you know and then and then
then it tends to kind of waiting through
jam and I stopped like before it run at
a time with you one of my anticipated
films of this year is something called
The Lion King no it's this small movie
that no one's heard of that there's a
company called Disney that's making it
right if I'm not mistaken you're voicing
scar butts that's true what the hell has
this process been like for you being a
part of that move
it's amazing you know and I'm very very
excited about the about the year and
excited for people to see it I think
it's going to be spectacular I think Jon
Favreau is you know incredible and and I
think it's gonna be fun
I saw at d23 and maybe at comic-con the
opening the opening of the movie and
it's you know very similar to the
animation and I think I was at
goosebumps I was tearing up I'm like oh
my god this is gonna be amazing
have you seen footage I've seen a bit of
footage and and obviously I've seen that
footage as well and you know I'm just so
thrilled about it and I cannot wait for
people to to people to see it I know
you're talking without talking I'm
trying to get a little yeah I don't know
what to say I wish I could help you but
but I guess I'll just say is it one of
the I'll leave it with this is that one
of these things were you've done a lot
of recording or is it sort of like
you've gone once or twice do you know
what I mean there's a bit I've done a
bit of recording yeah and you know so
it's it's it's it's an it it's an
intense experience and and also the kind
of just you know just what it means is
vast and huge and what it means to so
many people myself included and so I'm
very excited to bring this sort of
updated version of all of this to you
know to back to all of us and then
obviously to this this new generation so
it's exciting stuff I was gonna say it's
gonna be a worldwide event when it comes
out you know so enjoy I'm super happy
you guys got to come in today I thought
you did a great job and your story is
amazing
sincerely thank you for coming in I look
forward to your next film after this
thank you thank you thank you
you